alors que l'accord définitif pour
entériner le break 6 peine à arriver
c'est bien l'idée du fric site que
françois asselineau souhaite imposer
lors de la campagne des prochaines
européennes sortir de l'europe de l'euro
et de l'otan une idée qu'il défend
depuis maintenant 12 ans sa formation
lui père à d'ailleurs été lancée au
lendemain de la création du marché
commun par le traité de rome notre
appartenance à l'union européenne à
l'euro et un autre temps d'une part le
verrouille entièrement tous les choix
politiques c'est à dire que les
élections sont désormais vidé de
substance
en fait on a un plan de vol comme pour
un avion qui s'applique quel que soit le
commandant de bord qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche et les français le
voient et d'ailleurs ils commencent à le
comprendre y votent à droite ils votent
à gauche avaient des emplois même
politique cette politique qui nous
oblige qui oblige maquereau a supprimé
les sf qui l'obligent à démolir des
services publics les privatiser on est
en train de privatiser edf la sncf qui
s'attaquent ou à un autre au droit du
travail
aujourd'hui crédité de moins de 1% des
intentions de vote le 26 mai lui per
dénonce l'attitude des médias nationaux
qui refuserait de lui donnait la parole
alors qu'il compterait 34 mille
adhérents et des adhésions en hausse
quotidiennement reste qu'il faudra aussi
convaincre les électeurs moins d'un sur
deux pourrait se déplacer aux urnes
avant de pouvoir monter à la tribune du
parlement pour faire passer ses idées
que je serai au parlement européen et je
prendrai la parole à chaque fois pour
dénoncer les actes anti démocratiques de
la commission européenne pour dénoncer
cette machinerie bureaucratiques qui
coûtent des sommes tout à fait
considérable et pour montrer aux
français que la seule possibilité c'est
de sortir de l'union européenne une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
à rambouillet pour ce meeting de
françois asselineau le scrutin est prévu
le 26 mai